[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, everybody.
Welcome to Google
Developers Live.
My name's Ali, and today I'm
going to be talking to you
about Google Drive SDK.
This is our last session of the
year, and so we thought it
would be a nice idea to
wrap up what we've
been up to this year.
It's been quite exciting.
So I'm just going to run
through, in a vaguely
chronological order, all the
features we've implemented and
added to the Drive
SDK this year.
Once we've done that, we'll take
a little sneaky peek at
next year and what we have
planned and the directions
we're going.
So thanks for joining us.
As I say, the last
one of the year.
We'll be taking a break after
this, and we should be back
with you in the new year.
So the Google Drive SDK.
Well, as you all probably know,
or if you don't, we
launched Google Drive in
April of this year.
And Google Drive is Google's
cloud storage solution.
You put files in your Google
Drive, and they're available
to you from all your platforms,
from your phone,
from your tablet, from your
desktop computer, from your
laptop, from any way you can
connect to the internet, these
files are available to you.
So what is the Drive SDK, and
what were we trying to do?
Well, we thought we could add
value to Google Drive, the
consumer product.
How were we going to do that?
Well, if good apps exist, in
addition to the regular apps
that use Google Drive--
ie Google Docs, Google
Spreadsheets, Google
Presentations.
In addition to those, if we
could allow developers to
write awesome apps, the edit
files or create files, then
that would firstly be an
improvement for the user, ie,
you'd have more things that you
could do from your files
that are in Drive, it would
be an improvement for the
developers, for the people
writing those software,
because we would shift good
numbers of customers and new
customers to those
applications.
And so adding those two
together, that's a good thing
for Google Drive.
And that improves the Google
Drive ecosystem.
So how were we going
to do this?
Well, we had a long think, and
we decided that we want to
provide a platform for
developers to be able to write
applications that are as good
and as complex and as
effective as the Google Docs
editors that exist, ie, docs,
spreadsheets, and presentations,
and the others.
So we really wanted to provide
this entire platform.
And as you know, we've been
bringing in bits and pieces,
and gradually, as I'll show you
by the end of the day, I
think we're getting to a point
where you can actually do
that, which is exciting.
So let's go back to April.
What happened in April?
Well, we launched the
SDK Version 1.0.
Now, this was quite a small
chunk of what we have at the
moment, and what it essentially
did was allow your
application to open files
from Google Drive.
So your icon would appear in
Google Drive when a user
right-clicks on a file
that your application
knows how to open.
This is really useful for things
like Microsoft Project
files, for example, where there
are lots of them in
Google Drive but no
native editor.
So we allowed those
to be built.
We launched, in April, with
Google Drive at the same time.
So that's really important.
The platform was released as
part of the main product, not
an afterthought, really one of
the principal driving things
for the product.
So we launched there with
some key applications.
There were 18 of them, and they
all were able to open
files from Google Drive.
One example is HelloFax, which
you can right-click on a PDF,
and you can just fax
it to someone
directly from Google Drive.
This is the kind of value
that we wanted to add by
enabling the SDK.
So what could you do?
You could open files.
You could edit them offline,
and you could save
them back to Drive.
There were two types of
files, initially.
One of them are binary
files that are
stored in Google Drive.
That's like a standard file,
a text file, as I said, a
Project file, Excel
files, whatever.
But we also realized at that
point you may have some
different way of
storing files.
Your files may not
be real files.
They may be just columns in
a database, for example.
So we also produced this system
that allows you to keep
shortcuts in Google Drive.
So there's no binary data
stored there, but it's a
shortcut that, again, will
open correctly in your
application.
So we covered those bases.
As I said, the API was
quite small in scope.
It allowed you to read files,
save files, but nothing else.
For all the other management
functions of files and things
in Google Drive, you would have
to use the Documents List
API Version 3.0 that's been
around for a while.
And I'll talk about how we
gradually deprecated that.
One really important thing we
launched then with Google
Drive SDK V1.0 is
the file scope.
Now if I can explain that,
by scope, I mean
an OAuth 2.0 scope.
And that is, essentially, how
much permission you will give
an application to access
your Google Drive.
Before this, and many other
solutions for cloud storage,
when you get a token, when you
authorize an application,
you're really authorizing
them to access your
entire Google Drive.
And that was the situation
before.
We didn't think that
was ideal, really.
If you've got some photos
somewhere, and you've got some
other file somewhere you want
to edit one of these photos,
really, that application should
not have access to all
your Google Drive.
You may have sensitive
stuff there.
Obviously, most applications and
the big applications are
all very well behaved, but
still, this is a slight
privacy gap that we
didn't want users
to have to go through.
So we brought in this thing
called the file scope.
Now, the file scope means that
an application can only access
the files either that it's
created or that you've opened
with the application.
And by that, we very much
narrowed down the scope-- this
is why it's called a scope--
to files which you explicitly
say this application can
access them.
We found this was very good,
and users responded well.
You might think, well,
people don't care.
They just click on the button.
OK, grant access.
But that's not actually the
case, especially in corporate
environments where, really, the
things you're authorizing
these applications to do are
company secrets, which that's
just not a situation which
you're allowed to even do.
So that was the SDK
Version 1.0.
And as soon as we launched it,
we started working very hard
on the SDK Version 2.0.
And the SDK Version 2.0, wanted
to add functionality to
the SDK Version 1.0 that would
allow you to perform complete
file management and essentially,
replace the
Documents List API
Version 3.0.
So what kind of management of
files could we have here?
Well, obviously, when I say file
management, uploading,
downloading, but additional
things, the changes feed.
Well, you can fetch a feed that
lists all the changes
that a user has done in
their application.
And that's really useful for
synchronizing, making sure you
don't download things that
haven't changed,
that kind of situation.
There are revisions on files.
So as you know, Google Drive
is fully versioned like a
version control system.
When you make changes,
there are revisions.
You can access these different
revisions and get
the content for them.
So great.
So you've got a history.
Applications can leverage this
history to maybe roll back to
a previous revision and
things like that.
Exporting of Google documents,
and that's a
feature that's available.
So you can't actually download
the native Google Docs or
Google Sheets format,
because that
doesn't really mean anything.
It's not actually a file.
It's one of those examples of
one of the shortcuts that I
mentioned that is really
not quite but
rows in a table somewhere.
So you can export them with
the API to PDFs or to any
other formats that
are supported--
Excel or plain text, whatever
you happen to have.
And gradually we took these
features-- there are a few
other ones, but gradually we
tried to listen to what the
community wanted and especially
the things that
were missing from the Documents
List API and tried
to fill them out to have
a complete replacement.
And so over the year, we added
features such as service
account support.
Now, service accounts are a way
in which your application
can perform without being
manned, without a user there.
So there are two cases here.
One of them you could have a
service account for a domain,
which is really useful for
domain administrators to be
able to access all the files
or manage all the files for
people working in a company,
for example.
The second one is
application-owned accounts.
So your application can only
account, and essentially, they
become the user, and the Google
Drive is owned by the
application.
And it's really useful
for certain
application-based storage.
That application can share files
out to individuals if
they want, but really, that's
the choice of the application.
Again, really useful and
something which we had from
the Documents List API.
We gradually tried to improve
the authorization story.
So when you authorize--
when you open a file from Google
Drive, before you were
tied slightly to our
authorization flow.
And now you can provide your
own authorization flow, ie,
Vanilla OAuth, 2.0 and you can
get a token like that and
things still work.
So these were all features which
we were listening to you
guys, and thank you for raising
your feature requests.
Really, it's something we try
and listen to you guys, and we
try and do the best we can.
And as the year went on, we
added some other features, for
example, comment support.
This was one of the longest
standing feature requests I'd
heard from the Documents List
API, even back to Versions
1.0, 2.0, and 3.0.
And that was to be able to
manage comments on files.
So we added that feature.
You can manage comments on
native Google documents.
You can also add comments to
your own files, so your own
binary files, and you can anchor
them however you like.
There's a schema for anchoring,
and I suggest if
you're interested in that,
you check it out.
For example, a position on a
photo could be illustrated by
an x- and y-coordinates.
That's an example
of anchoring.
Or in a text file, you might
anchor to a line.
So this is really for you to be
able to add these features
to your application.
Again, back to the original
point, we want your
applications to be as good and
as complex and as rich as the
Google Docs applications.
We don't want there to
be any difference.
That's our mission, anyway.
One of my favorite features was
released towards the end
of the year, and that
was site publishing.
So if you haven't seen, it's
actually been one of our most
popular features.
Extremely simple.
Inside Google Drive, you can
put some files, make them
publicly available,
and then that's
treated as a web directory.
So relative links work.
JavaScript works.
CSS works.
And it's really great for,
what I would call,
lightweight, personal
website publishing.
A lot of applications popping
up that use that.
And we think that's
really great.
So if you have any feature
requests about that, again,
please get in touch with us.
And towards the very end of
year, one thing we've been
trying to do is really improve
our mobile story.
What do I mean by our
mobile story?
I mean the ability
for you to write
applications on mobile devices.
We've concentrated for now
on Android and iOS.
We are really keen to provide
equivalent comparable
experiences and good developer
experiences
on both those platforms.
So we're really not favoring
Android over iOS.
We appreciate the
needs of you.
And that is that you really
probably want to write your
applications for both, or you
may just want to write an
iPhone app or whatever.
That's really not
our business.
We want to make that experience
as good as
possible for you.
And likewise, we do that with
all the client libraries.
So we have a .NET
client library.
If you like programming in
.NET, that's great, too.
And also all the traditional,
more Google library based
things, like Java, Python,
JavaScript,
that kind of thing.
So we really tried to improve
our mobile story
to make that better.
We have quick starts for
both those platforms.
So if you want to get started
in five minutes, you can.
And we have complete
applications that do the same
thing, actually.
They take a photo, and they
just upload them.
But as you know, a full working
complete application
is better than a lot of
docs in some way.
You just unzip it, get it
running, and then you can
tweak it to do whatever
you like.
So we've tried to do that.
Again, if there any stumbling
blocks, please get
in touch with us.
One more thing I wanted to
mention is user interface
components in the Drive SDK.
Now, I've left this until
last, because it's
really a key point.
We try and provide you these
user interface components to
make your web apps better.
Now, what do I mean by
these components?
Well, we have two.
The first one is the picker--
the file picker--
which is essentially a file
browser that you can open up
with certain filters.
You can customize the way it
appears with side bars or
without side bars.
But this is a file browser
that's branded Google-like and
looks like Google Drive.
And it has the ability to
perform the open with that I
was talking about.
So that's the file picker.
You can just embed this in your
application with a few
lines of code.
Really, really useful.
You don't need to write
something to list and find the
icon for each file and then
redirect somewhere else and
this kind of thing.
It's there for you.
That's the first one.
The second one, we have
an equivalent
widget for sharing files.
So as you do in Google Drive,
when you click on the Share
button, it pops up, a list of
users, that kind of thing, and
share them.
You pick the ones you want to
share, and you choose what
access you want, whether it's
read access, write access,
ability to comment or not,
whether they get
notifications.
You can perform all that
functionality from inside your
own application.
So we tried to build these as
shortcuts for your application
to be able to use this
functionality.
Of course, if you want to write
your own widget, that's
absolutely fine too.
But hopefully, these will
get you started and
up and running quickly.
To follow on from that,
something we've tried to do to
make it easy for you is how
to discover applications.
How does a user find
your applications?
How do they know that you have
a file that opens images and
you can edit images?
How do you market
that to people?
Well, we use the Chrome
Web Store for this.
And in the Chrome Web Store,
you describe what kind of
files you can open.
And then from within Google
Drive, users can find these
applications.
So we find this is a really
useful vector to get people to
your application.
Again, we're not just doing
it because we're
selfless and we love you.
We do love you.
We're doing it because that's a
better experience for users.
It's better for a user to see,
oh, I can open this file if I
install this free application
that edits images.
Or say you want to add text
to an image, captions.
Well, we help you find them.
So always for the user.
Improve the user, and improve
Google Drive.
So that's really an overview
of the year.
It was vaguely in chronological
order.
It was just really a recap of
the features we've created and
the features we've added.
As I say, we're always
listening to you.
So if you really miss some
features or you want
something, let us know.
OK?
2012--
fantastic.
What are our plans for 2013?
Well, again, if I can go back
to the mission, we want your
applications to be as complex
and as good as the Google Docs
applications.
So we do appreciate that
at the moment,
really, you have an SDK.
You have a few APIs.
But it's not a complete
platform.
There are some areas which are
lacking and some things which
you can immediately think, hang
on, how do I do the cool
feature of Google
Docs currently?
Well, you can't, but these are
coming, and we are committed
to improving this experience.
So if I can mention
a few features.
The first one is our
collaborative platform.
This was demoed at Google I/O
this year, and it's really
progressed a lot.
What is it?
Well, it's a way in which
multiple users connected can
collaborate on a file.
It handles the shared data.
It handles the conflict
resolution.
It handles delivering these
messages of change, these
events, and these notifications
of when data changes.
It handles delivering all of
them to the correct browser
sessions at the right time.
So this is exactly what you
would see in Google Docs.
You see the cursors moving
around, someone's typing,
someone else is typing.
This is how that is performed,
and we're
providing that as a service.
As I said, if you want to see
the demo, check out Google
I/O. But it has advanced a lot
since then, and we really are
trying to make it
as simple and as
comfortable to use as possible.
At the same time, making it
as flexible to be able to
integrate with your existing--
whether you use Frameworks,
jQuery libraries, or
AngularJS--
however deep you are into NVC
in your JavaScript apps, we
want to be able to integrate
with that.
So that's coming soon.
We're really excited
about that.
In addition, we're trying
to improve the
platform around files.
One feature we've really
listened to people on is
application-based data.
So we're looking to provide a
way in which applications can
store data or files that really
they own inside a
user's drive.
So this will be essentially
hidden from the user.
They'll be able to delete it,
because it's their data
really, and it will
be using up quota.
So if it gets large, they
will want to delete it.
But really allows you
to save files that
your application owns.
And you can use that to
save various things.
In addition to that, we want to
provide metadata on files.
That's your arbitrary data.
You can decide any keys or any
values, and you can just put
them on the file.
And again, this time the user
can see that data, the user
can share that data,
that kind of thing.
It's more user-based, but this
will allow you to add your own
tags, for example, to a file,
which we, again, think is
really useful but also somewhat
lacking at the moment
to make Google Drive into a full
platform on which you can
build something.
So that's the metadata and
the application data.
In addition to that, we're
looking to provide another
[? long OS ?]
feature, which is push
notifications, which is when
you subscribe to something, a
file, when it changes, you are
notified of change.
So your application will
be notified somehow.
I won't go into the details,
but again, we talked about
this at Google I/O and
that's coming soon.
So no more need to
poll the changes
feed, has a file changed?
You subscribe once, and then
Google Drive will tell you,
hey look, this file
has changed.
Do you want to download
the file again?
You really can choose what you
want to do based on the
information you get.
So that's another
feature coming.
And so those are features.
In a general sense, we're
really keen on trying to
improve, as I said, the user
experience, but one of the
ways in which we're trying to
do this at the moment is we
really want to bring together
mobile and web applications.
So we think there's a
discrepancy at the moment.
An application might have a
mobile version, a desktop
version, and a web version.
Now, why do people have
to install all three?
Well, these are open questions,
really, but this is
the general experience
we're trying to fix.
So once we have a better
platform for you, we're going
to try and improve the
general integration
of the whole thing.
Again, I'm available always
for questions.
So if you really want to say,
oh, no, no, don't, please
don't add that feature,
just let me know.
And I'll talk to
you about that.
So that's where we're going.
Just a few reminders of ways in
which you can get in touch
with us and the community that
we're trying to build around
Google Drive SDK.
Firstly, these video sessions,
Google Developers Live, we do
two a week.
It's great of you, those
who attend, and we
hope you enjoy them.
So that's that.
Stack Overflow.
We've migrated to
a Stack Overflow
support model this year.
We've just found it way better,
because you get
experts from all sides of
computing who can contribute
to the answers to
your questions.
It's really great.
And we can have cross
connections with, for example,
the Java client library
or various other APIs.
So we're really enjoying that.
We've had 1,000 questions,
almost, on Stack Overflow, and
we hope to answer your
problems as soon
as they come up.
So talk to us on
Stack Overflow.
Thirdly, the Google+ community
we launched a few weeks ago.
Thank you.
There's been an amazing
response there.
We've got 2,700 and something
members and 10 to 15 to 20
posts a day.
That's really great.
We love engaging with
you like that.
We think Stack Overflow was
somewhat lacking in this much
more quick-term question and
answer, or you just want empty
your mind into the community
so people can
know what you're thinking.
Or you just want to announce
your application.
These kind of things are great,
and we're really happy
with how that community
is going.
Again, if you're interested,
check us out in the Google
Drive SDK community on Plus,
and come and say hello.
We're always there.
Finally, one thing we did this
quarter is we had a workshop
for some Google Drive
potential customers.
Now, we tried to pick--
and those who were
interested--
were generally the better
applications.
You know, big, established
applications,
not really for people.
It's not really a hack-a-thon
situation.
But these people came out
to Mountain View to the
Googleplex in California, and
we had a fun couple of days
where we tried to get people
over the initial integration
into their applications.
You know what it's like when
you're writing code.
Something blocks you, and then
you spend the next two hours
trying to work out
how to fix it.
It's just one line of code.
You're looking at Docs, and they
link to other docs, and
they link to other docs.
And you don't waste all this
time, because it's all
learning, but it does
take a lot of time.
So we tried to cut that out
by having Google engineers
available on the spot.
If you're interested, we will
be having future sessions.
If you are interested, please,
again, let us know, and we'll
see if we can accommodate you
in our future workshops.
So that's been us, 2012.
We look forward to seeing
you next year.
Thank you very much
for coming, and
have a merry holidays.
If you're on vacation,
enjoy them.
If you working, don't
work too hard.
Thank you very much.
Bye bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]